[Music]
bob's with us in atlanta hey bob welcome
to the ramsey show
hey dave hey george how you doing great
man what's up
so i need a new car pretty badly i've
been driving a 500 car for the last five
years
and it's getting to the point where
everything's starting to go on and it's
got 280 some thousand miles on it you're
doing it i've been shopping around
almost every day and i'm having trouble
finding a used car that
seems like a good deal a lot of these
cars are
seem like double what they should be
so i went out over the weekend and
looked at a new car and i know you say
that you have to be a millionaire to buy
a new car but
i just don't see the benefit right now
in saving 10 grand
to get a used car that's got you know 80
90 000 miles on it no warranty
so i don't know i don't know if right
now the situation warrants bending your
rules i just want to get your opinion on
that
well where are you at financially do you
have any debt
zero so i'm and babies have seven and i
probably got
a net worth of like 600 and why are you
driving a 500 dollar car
well it was it was a hand me down for my
mom i know but leave it in the side yard
and plant something in it oh my god 500
you got 600 000
dude go buy a car have you saved up for
this car already
yeah i could i i'm not there yet i'm
probably like a month away from having
cash board i looked at like a forty
thousand dollar jeep what's your sixty
thousand what's your six hundred
thousand in
uh
half of it is my house a quarter of it's
in a roth ira and another
quarter of it's between brokerage and
savings so you have the money in there
to go write a check and buy a car go buy
a 10 15 000 car and this crap that all
10 000 cars are worn out or 15 000 cars
are worn out dude you've been driving a
500 car
this is exponentially a better vehicle
than what you've been driving
okay you don't have to buy new there's
no i mean but you're saying he's saying
well it's not a deal right now because
of the car there's nothing that's a deal
right now new cars aren't a deal a lot
of new cars are going for over sticker
for the first time in my lifetime and
i'm 61 years old we've always been able
to buy cars on new cars under sticker
and some of them are sticker plus a lot
of them are sticker plus right now
because there's a shortage on them and
that's what's driving the used car
market bonkers as well is there's a
shortage so i would just go get me some
kind of car my god get out of a 500 car
and then you're gonna move out of move
again out of the car it's not that big a
thing it's not that big a deal so
i was looking at a uh
an escalade the other day and the brand
new escalades are bonkers people have
gone it's an upgrade they've got this
like 36 inch screen in them they're nuts
and uh the guy at the dealership is a
friend of mine he goes yeah i'll give it
to you for sticker and i'm like i'm
buying nothing for sticker
and he goes dude if you go up the street
to the other cadillac dealer they're 20
000 oversticker because you can't get
these wow and i'm like
unbelievable so i got neither that's
what i that's the move right um that was
a different move but yeah it worked i
mean i'm not mad at him it's just not
the time for me to buy a car obviously
now suit but dude you've got to fight
but a lot of people are in that boat
they're going with 500 cars a new car is
going to be way better but if you get a
5 000 car it's 10x what you're driving i
mean my god it's just you know anything
is an upgrade yeah a bicycle might be an
upgrade at this point so move up a
little
get something reasonable pay cash
here's the thing don't talk yourself
into stupid because of the market's gone
stupid
you know just because everybody else has
gone nuts doesn't mean you have to
and you can justify well because of
supply chain i was forced no you weren't
you weren't forced to do nothing you
were forced to do anything you may
overpay for that used car but not nearly
as much as you will that new car and
it's going to go down in value faster
and uh those new jeeps are sweet though
that's what that's what did him in he
went he made the mistake of going to
look at a brand new game and you smell
that leather and they are they're good
looking cars man they look great i'm a
carton nut
but um but he'll be a millionaire in no
time he'll get that jeep yeah yeah not
worried about it yeah and why do we say
be a millionaire before you buy a new
car well because depreciation is going
to crush that thing like a bug and a
millionaire can take the hit
tada his name is george campbell ladies
and gentlemen and he has all the answers
you could need
good stuff